customers at one scottish pub got a huge  surprise from coldplay's chris martin  who made an unexpected appearance on the  way back from the oh i'm gonna say this  wrong glastonbury music festival don't  kill me please okay sometimes i'm  dyslexic chris was even joined by his  girlfriend dakota johnson and found  himself behind the piano at one point  performing a sky full of stars for an  engaged couple very cute take a look  we'll see you back here next time bye  keisha  oh just do a bit of it okay what's your  name again hannah hannah ernst jeremiah  married in a minute in no 28th of august  but he is doing the food  and that's how he's outfit piano  [Music]  i'm gonna give you  [Music]  sorry  [Music]  i don't care  [Music]